In Bakersfield, California, in 1991, two boys stumbled upon a grisly discovery — the murdered body of a young woman. In the Shadows is the new podcast from Case File Presents, which follows the ensuing 32-year ordeal to uncover those responsible for the crime and to bring them to justice. The mystery riveted the desert town for years. This immediately zeroed in on the victim's longtime boyfriend, a beloved star athlete. But popular opinion was divided. Despite national attention and several trials, a conviction remained elusive, and many thought
1991年，在加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德，两名男孩偶然发现了一具令人毛骨悚然的尸体——一名年轻女性的遗体。《In the Shadows》是Case File Presents推出的全新播客，讲述了随后的32年里，人们为查明真凶并将其绳之以法所经历的艰难历程。这起悬案多年来一直困扰着这座沙漠小镇。调查很快锁定在受害者交往已久的男友身上，他是一位备受爱戴的明星运动员。但公众舆论却出现了分歧。尽管受到全国关注并经历了多次审判，定罪依然遥遥无期，许多人认为
the case would never be solved. That is, until this podcast turned over a new leaf. During the investigation of In the Shadows, several individuals revealed shocking information previously unknown to authorities. Ultimately, this new insight turned everything on its head and will bring you one step closer to deciding who's responsible for the murder. Previously only available with the Wondery Plus subscription, all seven episodes of In the Shadows are now available for free wherever you get your podcasts.
这起案件永远无法告破。直到这档播客开启了新的篇章。《In the Shadows》在调查过程中，几位知情者透露了此前当局从未掌握的惊人信息。最终，这些新见解颠覆了一切，并将带你更近一步去判断究竟谁该为这起谋杀案负责。此前仅限Wondery Plus订阅用户收听的《In the Shadows》全部七集，现已在各大播客平台免费上线。
Or you can listen ad-free on Wondery Plus. Stay tuned to hear the trailer at the end of today's episode. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium Feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers.
或者你也可以在Wondery Plus上收听无广告版本。请留意今天节目结尾的预告片。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人不安的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看你所用应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集最初作为付费订阅者的早期福利，发布在Casefile的Patreon、Apple Premium和Spotify Premium订阅源上。
These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support Casefile on your preferred platform. As at near 6 o'clock on an autumn morning in 1980, the odosius Glukarev was jolted awake by the sound of his apartment's doorbell. He rose from bed and headed to the door. No one was there.
这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。如需提前收听这些无广告剧集，你可以在你偏好的平台上支持Casefile。1980年一个秋日清晨近6点时，西奥多西·格卢卡列夫（Theodosius Glukarev）被公寓的门铃声惊醒。他起床走向门口，外面却空无一人。
He poked his head into the hallway, only to find the area empty and quiet. The odosius looked down and noticed a dark leather briefcase on the ground in front of him. Curious, the odosius laid it on its side, unclasped its latches and opened it up. Wedged inside and wrapped in cloth was the head of a woman. The odosius staggered back inside his apartment and immediately phoned the police. Officers arrived at the large nine-story building where the odosius lived with his wife and young daughter.
他探头看向走廊，发现那里空荡荡且一片寂静。西奥多西低头注意到脚下有一个深色的皮质公文包。出于好奇，他将包侧放，解开锁扣并打开了它。包里塞着一个用布包裹的东西，竟是一个女人的头颅。西奥多西踉跄着退回公寓，立即报了警。警察赶到了西奥多西与妻子及年幼女儿居住的那栋九层大楼。
Their apartment was just south of Kishinev, the Russian-named capital of Moldova, which at the time was part of the Soviet Union. The officers inspected the briefcase that had been left at the odosius's door. The decapitated head belonged to a brown-haired woman whose eyes had been gouged out. The odosius was adamant that he didn't recognize the woman, and there was nothing else inside the briefcase that hinted at her identity. However, there was a handwritten note addressed to Theodosius and scrolled in block capital letters, the note read,
他们的公寓位于摩尔多瓦首都基希讷乌（当时是苏联的一部分）以南。警察检查了留在西奥多西门前的公文包。那颗被斩下的头颅属于一名棕发女子，双眼已被挖去。西奥多西坚称他不认识这个女人，公文包里也没有其他暗示她身份的线索。然而，里面有一张写给西奥多西的手写字条，上面用大写印刷体写着：
Have you seen the gift? This is an example for you. The 10,000 rubles or your daughter will also be headless. In the evening you will come to the train station and bring money. Extortion was rare in Soviet Moldova, let alone in such a brutal form. At the time, 10,000 rubles was a large amount of money, the equivalent of around 50,000 US dollars in today's currency. Theodosius, who worked as a truck driver for a local brewery, was adamant that he didn't
你看到这份礼物了吗？这就是给你的教训。准备好一万卢布，否则你女儿也会身首异处。今晚你带着钱到火车站来。在苏联时期的摩尔多瓦，敲诈勒索本就罕见，更不用说以如此残忍的方式。当时，一万卢布是一笔巨款，相当于今天约5万美元。在当地一家啤酒厂担任卡车司机的西奥多西坚称他
have access to that kind of money. Unable to produce the large ransom in such a short amount of time, it was impossible for him to meet the killer's demands. Given that the killer knew where Theodosius lived, and that he had a daughter, it was clear that they knew Theodosius in some capacity. Yet, Theodosius couldn't think of anyone who would carry out such a gruesome act. Suspicious that he was hiding something, police covertly surveilled Theodosius the following day.
拿不出这么多钱。由于无法在如此短的时间内筹集到巨额赎金，他根本不可能满足凶手的要求。鉴于凶手知道西奥多西的住处，也知道他有个女儿，很明显凶手在某种程度上认识西奥多西。然而，西奥多西想不出有谁会做出如此残忍的行径。警方怀疑他有所隐瞒，于次日对西奥多西进行了秘密监视。
They discreetly tailed his truck as he drove from the brewery and onto the streets of Kishinev, where he eventually parked and entered a restaurant. It was an expensive establishment, the kind of place the affluent might dine at only once or twice a year for special occasions. Theodosius didn't stay long, certainly not enough time for him to eat. He soon returned to his truck and drove off. As the surveillance continued, Theodosius started behaving erratically. It seemed he realised that he was being followed.
他们悄悄跟踪他的卡车，看他从啤酒厂开出，驶入基希讷乌的街道，最终停下并走进了一家餐厅。那是一家昂贵的场所，是富人一年可能只会因特殊场合去一两次的地方。西奥多西没待多久，显然没时间吃饭。他很快回到卡车并开车离开。随着监视的继续，西奥多西的行为开始变得反常。他似乎意识到自己被跟踪了。
He took several abrupt turns and doubled back on his route before speeding through a red light. Police managed to catch up with him a little while later, by which point Theodosius had resumed going about his business. He entered a bakery and emerged with a cake in hand. He then walked to a nearby apartment building which was considered one of Kishinev's most prestigious addresses. Theodosius disappeared inside for some time before reappearing without the cake.
他突然转了好几个弯，在路线上折返，随后闯红灯加速行驶。不久后，警方设法追上了他，此时西奥多西已恢复了正常活动。他走进一家面包店，手里拿着一块蛋糕出来。随后，他走到附近一栋被认为是基希讷乌最高档的公寓楼。西奥多西在里面消失了一段时间，出来时手里已没有了蛋糕。
Later that day, he purchased a bouquet of flowers and visited another high-end apartment building on an adjacent street. Once again, he stayed inside briefly before exiting empty-handed. He then made his way home. He admitted to driving erratically after realising he was being pursued, but explained this was because he thought he was being trailed by the killer. Police put it to Theodosius that his job as a truck driver was really just a front for some kind of black market trading.
当天晚些时候，他买了一束花，去了隔壁街道的另一栋高档公寓楼。他再次在里面短暂停留后空手而出。随后他便回家了。他承认在意识到被跟踪后行为反常，但解释说这是因为他以为是凶手在跟踪他。警方质问西奥多西，他卡车司机的职业是否只是某种黑市交易的掩护。
He denied being involved in anything illegal, but eventually confessed that his visits to the two apartments were for clandestine meetings. Theodosius had been calling in on his girlfriends. Neither of his girlfriends knew about the other, nor were they aware that Theodosius was married with a child. Although he wasn't a particularly remarkable or wealthy man, Theodosius was a serial womaniser who often bragged to his friends about his extramarital affairs. Others were satisfied that Theodosius wasn't part of any underworld scheming, but had been
他否认参与任何非法活动，但最终承认他去那两间公寓是为了私会。西奥多西一直在私会他的情妇。他的两个情妇互不知情，也不知道西奥多西已婚并育有一女。尽管西奥多西并非什么出众或富有的人，但他是个连环风流浪子，经常向朋友吹嘘自己的婚外情。其他人则确信西奥多西并未参与任何地下阴谋，而是
targeted for some other specific reason. They considered the possibility that the severed head might have belonged to one of his girlfriends. Perhaps the woman's husband had found out about the affair and taken revenge. Theodosius claimed that his girlfriends were both alive and well, and it was quickly confirmed that he was telling the truth. Both of his girlfriends attended the police station for questioning, but neither recognized the face of the woman from the briefcase. This sent investigators back to square one.
因为其他特定原因成为了目标。他们考虑了那颗断头可能属于他其中一位情妇的可能性。也许是女人的丈夫发现了这段婚外情并进行了报复。西奥多西声称他的两个情妇都安然无恙，警方很快证实他所言非虚。他的两个情妇都到警察局接受了问询，但两人都不认识公文包里那个女人的脸。这让调查人员回到了原点。
Unable to figure out why Theodosius was being extorted, they worked to identify the victim. Perhaps if they knew who she was, her connection to Theodosius would become clear. After exhausting all other avenues, investigators sought permission from their country's leadership to employ a tactic that had never been used in the Soviet Union before. They asked to show a photograph of the woman's head on national television in the hope that someone would recognize her face. Their request was granted. With as much care as possible, the woman's face was cleaned to be presentable to the public.
由于无法弄清西奥多西为何遭到勒索，他们转而试图确认受害者的身份。也许只要知道她是谁，她与西奥多西的联系就会明朗。在尝试了所有其他途径后，调查人员请求国家领导层批准使用一种苏联从未用过的策略。他们请求在全国电视上播放这名女子头颅的照片，希望有人能认出她的脸。请求得到了批准。他们尽可能小心地清理了女子的面部，以便向公众展示。
Her hair was neatly combed down and pinned behind her head. Glass spheres were inserted into her empty eye sockets and her eyelids were closed over them. A photograph was taken and broadcast on national television across Soviet Moldova. Although a white scarf tied beneath her chin concealed her severed neck, it was obvious to most that she was deceased. That night, seven-year-old Viktor Trasen sat in front of his family's television set, eyes glued to a rerun of a popular Soviet musical miniseries, Dartenyan and the Three
她的头发被整齐地梳理并别在脑后。眼眶里被塞入了玻璃球，眼睑也合上了。照片拍摄完成后，在苏联摩尔多瓦的全国电视台上进行了广播。尽管下巴下系着的白色围巾遮住了断颈，但大多数人一眼就能看出她已经遇害。那天晚上，七岁的维克多·特拉森（Viktor Trasen）坐在家里的电视机前，目不转睛地看着一部广受欢迎的苏联音乐迷你剧《达达尼昂与三个
Musketeers. Viktor lived with his mother and Aileen's grandmother in an apartment in Kishinev. His grandmother was content to let Viktor enjoy the swashbuckling action on screen as the young boy had recently been overcome with anxiety and the program provided a much needed distraction. A few nights earlier, Viktor's mother, Irina, had left home to catch up with a friend. She said that she would only be gone for 30 minutes, but by the time Viktor awoke the next morning, she still hadn't returned.
火枪手》的重播。维克多与母亲和祖母住在基希讷乌的一间公寓里。祖母很乐意让维克多享受屏幕上惊险刺激的动作场面，因为这个小男孩最近一直焦虑不安，而这部剧提供了一个急需的消遣。几天前，维克多的母亲伊琳娜（Irina）离家去见一位朋友。她说她只会离开30分钟，但当维克多第二天早上醒来时，她仍未归来。
Viktor took himself to school and later made dinner for himself and his grandmother. He kept this up all the while bombarding his grandmother with questions about his mother's whereabouts. But she couldn't give him any answers. Viktor's concerns for Irina grew until he parked himself in front of the television one night for a mental reprieve. All of a sudden, Dartenyan and the Three Musketeers was interrupted by a special news bulletin. A photograph of a woman appeared on screen.
维克多自己去上学，后来还为自己和祖母做了晚饭。他一直坚持这样做，同时不断地问祖母关于母亲下落的问题。但祖母给不出任何答案。维克多对伊琳娜的担忧与日俱增，直到有一天晚上，他坐在电视机前寻求精神上的解脱。突然，《达达尼昂与三个火枪手》被一则特别新闻简报打断。屏幕上出现了一张女人的照片。
Viktor immediately recognized the woman as his mother, Irina. He was confused as to why she was on television, but excited that he would finally see her again. He wrote down the number on the screen and called it first thing the following morning. Investigators could now identify the mutilated woman as Irina Trassen, but they still had no idea why she had been targeted. Theodosius Glukarev claimed he didn't know Irina and there was no evidence to suggest the pair had ever crossed paths.
维克多立刻认出那个女人就是他的母亲伊琳娜。他很困惑为什么她会出现在电视上，但又很兴奋终于能再见到她。他记下了屏幕上的号码，并在第二天一早拨打了电话。调查人员现在可以确认这名被残害的女子是伊琳娜·特拉森，但他们仍然不知道她为何成为目标。西奥多西·格卢卡列夫声称他不认识伊琳娜，也没有证据表明两人曾有过交集。
As investigators tried to determine why Irina was murdered as part of an extortion plot against a stranger, they received a phone call. Another package had just arrived at Theodosius's front door. The package wasn't in a briefcase this time, but wrapped in paper. Again, it was accompanied by a handwritten note addressed to Theodosius in the same block capital letters as the first. This one read, you still don't want to pay, then kiss a woman's hand. Inside the package was the severed hand of a woman.
正当调查人员试图确定伊琳娜为何会成为针对陌生人的勒索阴谋的受害者时，他们接到了一个电话。西奥多西的前门又收到一个包裹。这次包裹不是装在公文包里，而是用纸包着的。同样，里面附有一张写给西奥多西的手写字条，字迹与第一张一样，都是大写印刷体。这张字条写着：你还是不想付钱，那就亲吻女人的手吧。包裹里是一只被切断的女人手。
Forensic analysis confirmed it did not belong to Irina Trassen. A second woman had been killed and once again the police were left with no clues as to this victim's identity. The note continued, in three days you will bring the money to the train station, otherwise we will chop your daughter to pieces. The note hadn't referred to Theodosius's daughter by her name, Oxana, but this was the second direct threat against her. Two days later, Oxana was making her way home from school.
法医分析证实这只手不属于伊琳娜·特拉森。第二个女人遇害了，警方再次没有任何关于这名受害者身份的线索。字条继续写道：三天后你把钱带到火车站，否则我们就把你女儿剁成碎片。字条没有提到西奥多西女儿的名字奥克萨娜（Oxana），但这已经是第二次直接威胁她了。两天后，奥克萨娜放学回家。
Just as she reached the entrance to her family's apartment block, a man approached and offered her some candy. All of a sudden, two other men who had been a short distance behind Oxana leapt into action. They ran up to the man, grabbed him and wrestled him to the ground. The pair were undercover police officers tasked with protecting Oxana. The young girl shouted at the police officers, let Uncle Sasha go, he's good. Realising the man was known to Oxana, the officers backed off. While he wasn't technically her uncle, he was a close friend of her family.
就在她到达自家公寓楼入口时，一名男子走过来递给她一些糖果。突然，两名一直跟在奥克萨娜身后不远处的男子冲了上来。他们跑向那名男子，抓住他并将其按倒在地。这两人是负责保护奥克萨娜的便衣警察。小女孩对警察大喊：放开萨沙叔叔，他是好人。意识到这名男子是奥克萨娜认识的人，警察退后了。虽然他严格来说不是她的叔叔，但他确实是她家的一位密友。
As a precaution, the police thoroughly looked into Uncle Sasha. They discovered that he worked at the local confectionary factory, which explained why he had candy on hand. A married father, Uncle Sasha had received a government award for his hard work and commitment to the Soviet Union. With no criminal record or anything else to highlight him as dangerous, he was ruled out as being the killer who was extorting theodosius. Case file will be back shortly.
作为预防措施，警方彻底调查了萨沙叔叔。他们发现他在当地的糖果厂工作，这解释了他为什么随身带着糖果。萨沙叔叔是一位已婚父亲，曾因工作努力和对苏联的贡献获得过政府奖励。由于没有犯罪记录，也没有其他迹象表明他有危险，他被排除了作为勒索西奥多西的凶手的嫌疑。Case file稍后回来。
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support case file to continue to deliver quality content. Unable to pin down a suspect, police realised that theodosius would have to meet the killer's demands in order to flush him out. Three nights after receiving the severed hand, theodosius presented himself at the Kishinev train station. He carried a briefcase containing 10,000 rubles.
感谢您通过收听本集赞助商的广告来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case file继续提供优质内容。由于无法锁定嫌疑人，警方意识到西奥多西必须满足凶手的要求才能将其引出。在收到断手的三晚后，西奥多西出现在基希讷乌火车站。他带着一个装有一万卢布的公文包。
The money had been hastily gathered by the Ministry of Internal Affairs to facilitate the requested handover. Dozens of undercover police officers inconspicuously milled about the station, keeping a close eye on anyone who moved close to theodosius. Given the second ransom letter had contained the pronoun we, police were mindful that multiple perpetrators could be involved and could also be watching the situation unfold. Suddenly, a lone man approached theodosius. The officers observed intently, waiting to make their move.
这笔钱是内务部匆忙筹集的，旨在促成要求的移交。数十名便衣警察在车站里不动声色地徘徊，密切注视着任何靠近西奥多西的人。鉴于第二封勒索信中使用了“我们”这个代词，警方意识到可能涉及多名作案者，他们也可能正在观察事态的发展。突然，一名男子独自走向西奥多西。警察们全神贯注地观察着，等待采取行动。
The man was holding a cigarette and he asked theodosius for a light. He then continued on his way. He was not the man they were expecting. Several hours passed until it became abundantly clear the exchange wasn't going to take place. Either the killer never showed up, or they had realised it was a setup. During they were dealing with our quote, bloodthirsty maniac, police had to act quickly to prevent more women from being murdered and mutilated. Wild rumours were spreading, with some claiming the mutilations were the act of necromancer
那名男子手里拿着一支烟，向西奥多西借火。随后他便继续前行。他不是他们预期的那个人。几个小时过去了，直到很明显交易不会发生。要么是凶手从未出现，要么是他们意识到这是一个圈套。在处理我们所谓的“嗜血狂魔”时，警方必须迅速采取行动，以防止更多的女性被谋杀和残害。各种疯狂的谣言四起，有人声称这些残害行为是盗墓的死灵法师所为。
sorcerers who were digging up graves. Others feared that an unidentified serial killer known as Metal Fang had arrived in Kishinev to continue his spree. Some turned their suspicions towards theodosius Glukarev himself. Word was circulating that he had recently cut ties with a criminal group who were now using the extortions as a method of intimidation. With all these leads and more having reached dead ends, investigators revisited the evidence, beginning with the two extortion letters.
其他人则担心一个被称为“金属獠牙”的身份不明的连环杀手已经抵达基希讷乌继续作案。有些人将怀疑转向了西奥多西·格卢卡列夫本人。有传言称他最近切断了与一个犯罪团伙的联系，该团伙现在正利用勒索作为恐吓手段。随着所有这些线索及其他线索都陷入死胡同，调查人员重新审视了证据，从两封勒索信开始。
Everything was niggling at one particular investigator. As he agonised over each word of the letters, the realisation suddenly dawned. In both notes the author had referred to Theodosius by his nickname, Fedos. Upon further questioning, Theodosius revealed that he didn't like his full name and would generally ask colleagues and associates to call him Fedor for short. In turn, close friends and family took to calling him Fedos. Realising the killer was amongst Theodosius' immediate circle, investigators narrowed down the list of suspects until just one person remained.
一切都让一位调查人员感到困惑。当他苦苦思索信中的每一个字时，他突然恍然大悟。在两张字条中，作者都称呼西奥多西为他的昵称“费多斯”（Fedos）。经过进一步询问，西奥多西透露他不喜欢自己的全名，通常会要求同事和熟人叫他“费多尔”（Fedor）作为简称。反过来，亲密的朋友和家人开始叫他“费多斯”。意识到凶手就在西奥多西的亲近圈子里，调查人员缩小了嫌疑人名单，直到只剩下一人。
A few years earlier, Dmitri Kuzinsev was enjoying his wedding reception when he realised his new wife wasn't by his side. He searched the venue and eventually found her in a compromising position with another man. The man was Dmitri's second cousin, Theodosius Glukarev. Enraged, Dmitri chased Theodosius with a knife threatening to kill him. The guests disarmed Dmitri and tied him down before he could inflict any injuries. As Theodosius was led from the party, Dmitri shouted that he would find him and cut him.
几年前，德米特里·库津采夫（Dmitri Kuzinsev）正在享受他的婚宴时，发现新婚妻子不在身边。他搜寻了会场，最终发现她与另一个男人举止亲密。那个男人是德米特里的表弟，西奥多西·格卢卡列夫。德米特里大怒，拿着刀追赶西奥多西，威胁要杀了他。客人们在德米特里造成伤害前解除了他的武装并将他捆绑起来。当西奥多西被带离聚会时，德米特里大喊他会找到他并砍了他。
Investigators explored Dmitri's background and discovered that he was already on the radar of the Soviet financial police, having been suspected of the theft and illegal sale of rare Soviet property. He also worked as a dining car manager for Soviet railways, which was significant given the killer had named the Kishinev train station as the extortion money drop site. Undercover officers boarded Dmitri's train in order to confront him, one disguised as a railway inspector spotted Dmitri and called him by name. Sensing he was in trouble, Dmitri jumped from the train and ran.
调查人员深入调查了德米特里的背景，发现他已经在苏联金融警察的监视之下，因涉嫌盗窃和非法销售稀有苏联财产而受到怀疑。他还担任苏联铁路的餐车经理，考虑到凶手将基希讷乌火车站定为勒索金投放点，这一点意义重大。便衣警察登上了德米特里的火车以便与他对质，一名伪装成铁路检查员的警察发现了德米特里并叫出了他的名字。感觉到有麻烦，德米特里跳下火车逃跑了。
The chase was short-lived as Dmitri tripped over the tracks and was swiftly apprehended. Dmitri denied any wrongdoing, but when he learned he was under suspicion for murder and extortion, he quickly confessed to the crimes against Soviet property. He vehemently denied having anything to do with the murders. With a little bit more digging, police were able to verify that Dmitri was telling them the truth. He was a criminal, but he was not the killer they were looking for. The son had just set as university student Olga Lebedeva stood alone in Kishinev Central
追捕时间很短，德米特里被铁轨绊倒，迅速被捕。德米特里否认有任何不当行为，但当他得知自己因谋杀和勒索受到怀疑时，他很快承认了针对苏联财产的犯罪。他极力否认与谋杀案有任何关系。经过进一步挖掘，警方能够证实德米特里说的是实话。他是个罪犯，但他不是他们要找的凶手。太阳刚刚落山，大学生奥尔加·列别杰娃（Olga Lebedeva）独自站在基希讷乌中央
Park waiting for her date. Several months prior, Olga had responded to a personal ad in the local newspaper and had been corresponding with the man ever since. This was the first time they were going to meet in person. Olga's date soon approached, carrying a bouquet of flowers. He handed them to her and immediately apologized, saying he couldn't stay for their date as some important business had just come up. He then turned around and hurried away.
公园等待约会对象。几个月前，奥尔加在当地报纸上回复了一则征友广告，此后一直与那名男子通信。这是他们第一次见面。奥尔加的约会对象很快走近，手里拿着一束花。他把花递给她，并立即道歉，说他因为刚处理了一些重要事务，无法留下来赴约。随后他转身匆匆离开。
Confused, Olga decided to head home. As she walked through the park along a tree-lined path, she heard someone approaching from behind. Olga quickened her pace, so did the person behind her. Suddenly, Olga was jerked backwards and thrown to the ground. A man stood over her before pulling her into some bushes nearby. He wrapped a hand around Olga's neck and squeezed, using his other hand to hold up a knife. As Olga fought for her life, the contents of her bags spilled onto the ground.
困惑的奥尔加决定回家。当她走在公园里一条林荫小道上时，听到身后有人走近。奥尔加加快了脚步，身后的人也加快了脚步。突然，奥尔加被猛地向后一拽，摔倒在地。一个男人站在她上方，随后将她拖入附近的灌木丛。他用一只手掐住奥尔加的脖子，另一只手拿着一把刀。当奥尔加拼命挣扎时，包里的东西散落在地上。
She grabbed the nearest item, her hairbrush, and jammed it as hard as she could into the man's groin. He released his grip, dropped his knife, and gripped his crotch as he curled over in pain. Olga scrambled to her feet. As she rushed back onto the footpath, her attacker yelled out, I will catch up with you, creature, and I will cut you into pieces. Olga ran as fast as she could, right into the path of someone who had slipped away from a birthday party early to head home.
她抓起最近的东西——她的发梳，尽全力猛地扎进男人的腹股沟。他松开了手，丢下刀，捂着裆部痛苦地蜷缩起来。奥尔加挣扎着站起身。当她冲回人行道时，袭击者大喊：我会抓住你的，畜生，我会把你剁成碎片。奥尔加拼命奔跑，正好撞上了一个为了早点回家而提前离开生日派对的人。
They took her to the police station, where the officer on duty was intrigued to learn that Olga's attacker had threatened to cut her into pieces. Police across the city had been briefed about the unidentified killer who had been sending mutilated remains to Theodosius Glukarev. The officer was aware that in one of the notes the perpetrator had used the phrase, We will chop your daughter to pieces. Seeing Olga had survived an encounter with the killer, hundreds of police officers descended on Kishinev's Central Park to scour the area for clues.
他们把她带到了警察局，值班警官得知奥尔加的袭击者曾威胁要将她“剁成碎片”时感到很震惊。全市的警察都已接到关于那个向西奥多西·格卢卡列夫寄送残肢的身份不明凶手的简报。警官意识到，在其中一张字条中，作案者曾使用过“我们会把你女儿剁成碎片”这句话。看到奥尔加在与凶手的遭遇中幸存下来，数百名警察涌入基希讷乌中央公园，搜寻线索。
They soon came upon a plot of freshly disturbed earth. The area was dug up, revealing a shallow grave containing the body of a young woman. Her shirt was torn open, and her trousers and underwear were pulled below her knees. There were multiple stub wounds to her chest and around her genitals. Most significantly, her head was missing. Police had just uncovered the body of Irina Trasin. Now they were absolutely certain that the same man who attacked Olga Lebedeva had killed Irina and that he had used the expansive parklands as his hunting ground.
他们很快发现了一块刚被翻动过的土地。该区域被挖开，露出了一个浅坑，里面埋着一名年轻女性的尸体。她的衬衫被撕开，裤子和内衣被拉到膝盖以下。她的胸部和生殖器周围有多处刺伤。最重要的是，她的头不见了。警方刚刚发现了伊琳娜·特拉森的尸体。现在他们完全确定，袭击奥尔加·列别杰娃的那个男人就是杀害伊琳娜的凶手，并且他一直将广阔的公园作为他的狩猎场。
Olga struggled to recall much about her ordeal as it was dark and happened quickly, but something about her assailant seemed familiar. She was certain it was the same man she had met for a date 30 minutes earlier. Olga explained that she had been corresponding with this man for some time. The investigators asked if she had kept any of the letters. Lucky for them, she had kept them all. Each of the letters were handwritten and had been signed off with the sender's name, Alexander Skrinik.
奥尔加努力回忆关于她遭遇的细节，因为当时天很黑且发生得很快，但袭击者的某些特征让她感到熟悉。她确信这就是她30分钟前见面的那个男人。奥尔加解释说她已经与这个男人通信有一段时间了。调查人员问她是否保留了任何信件。幸运的是，她把信都留下了。每一封信都是手写的，并署有寄件人的名字：亚历山大·斯克里尼克（Alexander Skrinik）。
The police were stunned. They knew Skrinik. Across most Eastern European countries, the name Alexander is commonly shortened to Sasha. Alexander Skrinik was Uncle Sasha, the man who had approached Theodosius' daughter with candy weeks earlier. A background check of Skrinik had ruled him out as a suspect, but now investigators were certain he was the killer they'd been looking for. They just needed to find some compelling evidence to prove it.
警方惊呆了。他们认识斯克里尼克。在大多数东欧国家，亚历山大这个名字通常缩写为萨沙。亚历山大·斯克里尼克就是萨沙叔叔，那个几周前带着糖果接近西奥多西女儿的男人。对斯克里尼克的背景调查曾将他排除在嫌疑人之外，但现在调查人员确信他就是他们一直在寻找的凶手。他们只需要找到一些令人信服的证据来证明这一点。
No viable forensics had been found on Irina Trassen's head or body, nor on the unidentified severed hand left at Theodosius' door. This just left the extortion notes and the letters to Olga. A handwriting expert was brought in, but when he looked at the samples, he shrugged. The extortion notes had been printed in block capitals, whereas the letters were in Skrinik's cursive handwriting. It wasn't possible to conclusively compare the two. Meanwhile, Alexander Skrinik was called to attend the Military Registration and Enlistment
在伊琳娜·特拉森的头颅或尸体上，以及留在西奥多西门前的身份不明的断手上，都没有发现可用的法医证据。这只剩下勒索信和给奥尔加的信。一位笔迹专家被请来，但他看着样本耸了耸肩。勒索信是用大写印刷体打印的，而信件则是斯克里尼克的草书手写体。无法确凿地比较两者。与此同时，亚历山大·斯克里尼克被传唤到军事登记和征兵
Office. At 27 years of age, Skrinik was still subject to Soviet conscription until his next birthday. He arrived promptly at the military office and was shown into an adjacent room. He, along with about 20 other conscripts, filled in the necessary paperwork. Afterwards, they were told that a military representative would be in touch soon. Alexander Skrinik then left the building. Unbeknownst to Skrinik, the entire registration process was a setup by police as a way to obtain his handwriting.
办公室。27岁的斯克里尼克在下次生日之前仍需服苏联兵役。他准时到达军事办公室，被带进了一个隔壁房间。他和其他约20名应征入伍者一起填写了必要的文件。之后，他们被告知军事代表很快会与他们联系。亚历山大·斯克里尼克随后离开了大楼。斯克里尼克不知道的是，整个登记过程是警方为了获取他的笔迹而设的局。
The call, the staff, and the other conscripts had all been staged. The military registration papers were required to be completed in block capital letters. As soon as Skrinik left, the registration papers were given to the handwriting expert who was waiting behind the scenes. Within half an hour, the expert unequivocally concluded that the block letters in Skrinik's registration form were an exact match to those in the two extortion notes sent to Theodosius. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
电话、工作人员和其他应征者都是安排好的。军事登记表要求用大写印刷体填写。斯克里尼克一离开，登记表就被交给了在幕后等待的笔迹专家。半小时内，专家明确断定斯克里尼克登记表上的大写字母与寄给西奥多西的两封勒索信中的字迹完全吻合。Case file稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商的广告来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support case file to continue to deliver quality content. That evening, police arrived at Alexander Skrinik's apartment, only to be told by Skrinik's wife that her husband had just left to see a movie. A contingent of plainclothes police officers quickly descended on the Patriar Cinema in central Kishinyev. The film that was about to be shown was a Soviet disaster film called Aircrew, which depicted the story of a plane full of passengers trying to take off during an earthquake.
感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case file继续提供优质内容。那天晚上，警察赶到亚历山大·斯克里尼克的公寓，却被斯克里尼克的妻子告知，她丈夫刚出门去看电影。一队便衣警察迅速包围了基希讷乌市中心的帕特里亚电影院。即将放映的电影是一部名为《机组人员》（Aircrew）的苏联灾难片，讲述了一架载满乘客的飞机在地震中试图起飞的故事。
Aircrew had debuted earlier in 1980, but due to its popularity, it was being re-screened to a sold-out audience. Police searched for Skrinik amongst the throng of cinema-goers milling outside the building and inside the foyer waiting for the movie to start. Eventually, they spotted Skrinik. He was approaching the cinema accompanied by a young woman. One quick-thinking detective approached the couple. He explained that the film was sold out, but he had two tickets he was willing to sell.
《机组人员》于1980年初首映，但由于广受欢迎，正在向满座的观众重映。警察在电影院外徘徊的影迷中以及等待电影开始的大厅里搜寻斯克里尼克。最终，他们发现了斯克里尼克。他正陪着一名年轻女子走向电影院。一名机智的侦探走近这对男女。他解释说电影票已售罄，但他有两张票愿意出售。
Skrinik was interested. The detective suggested that they walk around the side of the building where it was much quieter in order to make the exchange. Skrinik and the young woman happily accompanied the detective. Once they were away from the crowd, other officers converged on Skrinik and placed him under arrest. At the police station, Alexander Skrinik remained indignant. He denied having done anything wrong and pointed to his Government Labor Award and membership of the Soviet Communist Party as proof of his good character and innocence.
斯克里尼克很感兴趣。侦探建议他们走到大楼侧面，那里安静得多，以便进行交易。斯克里尼克和那名年轻女子高兴地陪同侦探前往。一旦他们远离人群，其他警察便围住斯克里尼克并将他逮捕。在警察局，亚历山大·斯克里尼克依然愤愤不平。他否认做了任何错事，并指着他的政府劳动奖章和苏联共产党党员身份，作为他品行端正和清白的证明。
However, once investigators revealed the ruse at the enlistment office and the handwriting analysis evidence they had against him, Skrinik abandoned his charade. Skrinik then made a surprise confession. Arena Trassen was not his first murder victim. Several years earlier in the mid-1970s, he had been living and working in Yakutia, a sparsely populated Soviet region in the Far East of Russia. There, Skrinik met and murdered a flight attendant named Nina Puganova. After killing Nina, Skrinik removed her breasts and genitals before dumping her body.
然而，当调查人员揭露了征兵办公室的诡计以及他们掌握的笔迹分析证据后，斯克里尼克放弃了伪装。斯克里尼克随后做出了令人震惊的供述。伊琳娜·特拉森并不是他的第一个受害者。几年前的70年代中期，他曾在俄罗斯远东地区人口稀少的苏联地区雅库特生活和工作。在那里，斯克里尼克遇见并谋杀了一名名叫尼娜·普加诺娃（Nina Puganova）的空姐。杀害尼娜后，斯克里尼克切除了她的乳房和生殖器，然后抛弃了她的尸体。
The remains were later discovered, however authorities at the time were unable to solve Nina's murder. Skrinik disclosed that he had stabbed Arena Trassen to death after meeting her for ice cream at the park where her body was later found. He decapitated Arena post-mortem, kept her head, before burying her body in a shallow grave. Skrinik's third and final victim was a woman named Anastasia Mikhailova. Like Arena before her, Skrinik had met Anastasia for ice cream before stabbing her to death
遗体后来被发现，但当时的当局无法破获尼娜的谋杀案。斯克里尼克透露，他在公园里与伊琳娜·特拉森见面吃冰淇淋后，将她刺死，尸体后来就是在那里被发现的。他在死后将伊琳娜斩首，保留了她的头颅，然后将她的尸体埋在一个浅坑里。斯克里尼克的第三个也是最后一个受害者是一个名叫阿纳斯塔西娅·米哈伊洛娃（Anastasia Mikhailova）的女人。像之前的伊琳娜一样，斯克里尼克在与阿纳斯塔西娅见面吃冰淇淋后将她刺死，
and mutilating her body. This time Skrinik had kept Anastasia's severed hand as a souvenir. Having already discovered Arena's headless body, police probed Skrinik for the whereabouts of Anastasia's remains. Skrinik said that Anastasia was buried in a different park and offered to take them to the exact location. The following day, he escorted investigators to an area of Woodland. He pointed to the exact location where officers should start digging.
并残害了她的尸体。这一次，斯克里尼克保留了阿纳斯塔西娅被切断的手作为纪念品。在已经发现了伊琳娜的无头尸体后，警方追问斯克里尼克关于阿纳斯塔西娅遗体的下落。斯克里尼克说阿纳斯塔西娅被埋在另一个公园，并主动提出带他们去确切地点。第二天，他陪同调查人员来到一片林地。他指出了警察应该开始挖掘的确切位置。
Sure enough, about a foot below the surface, police uncovered the remains of Anastasia Mikhailova, who was missing a hand. Investigators had everything they needed from Anastasia, a full confession to the murders and Anastasia's remains. What they now wanted was Skrinik's motive for these brutal slayings. Skrinik explained that about a year into his marriage, after his son was born, he was dissatisfied with his life. Specifically, Skrinik wanted more sex.
果然，在地表下约一英尺处，警方发现了阿纳斯塔西娅·米哈伊洛娃的遗体，她少了一只手。调查人员从阿纳斯塔西娅那里得到了他们需要的一切：一份完整的谋杀供词和阿纳斯塔西娅的遗体。他们现在想要的是斯克里尼克进行这些残忍杀戮的动机。斯克里尼克解释说，在他结婚大约一年后，儿子出生后，他对生活感到不满。具体来说，斯克里尼克想要更多的性生活。
He placed a personal ad in the local newspaper with the intention of attracting a woman who would be willing to sleep with him. Eventually, Skrinik met up with a woman who responded to his ad and the two had sex. As a result, Skrinik contracted a venereal disease. This instigated Skrinik's hatred towards women, who he now blamed for his unhappy marriage and the lack of sex to which he felt entitled. Skrinik appointed himself as a, quote, orderly of nature and decided that it was his calling to destroy women.
他在当地报纸上刊登了一则征友广告，意图吸引愿意与他发生关系的女性。最终，斯克里尼克与一名回应他广告的女性见面并发生了性关系。结果，斯克里尼克染上了性病。这激发了斯克里尼克对女性的仇恨，他现在将自己不幸的婚姻和缺乏他认为自己应得的性生活归咎于女性。斯克里尼克自封为“自然的秩序维护者”，并决定摧毁女性是他的使命。
As to why he extorted his friend Theodosius Glukarev, Skrinik simply explained that he was jealous of Theodosius, who boasted of his active sex life and multiple extramarital affairs. His intention was to, quote, let this womanize a shake with fear and at the same time fork out. A few months after his arrest, Alexander Skrinik stood trial for the murders of Nina Puganova, Irina Trasin and Anastasia Mikalova. At the start of his testimony, he boasted that anyone with a weak disposition should
至于他为何勒索朋友西奥多西·格卢卡列夫，斯克里尼克简单地解释说，他嫉妒西奥多西，因为西奥多西吹嘘自己活跃的性生活和多段婚外情。他的意图是“让这个风流浪子颤抖，同时掏出钱来”。被捕几个月后，亚历山大·斯克里尼克因谋杀尼娜·普加诺娃、伊琳娜·特拉森和阿纳斯塔西娅·米哈伊洛娃而受审。在证词开始时，他吹嘘说任何意志薄弱的人都应该
leave the room. Skrinik then recited his crimes without any hint of remorse. He told the court that he enjoyed murdering the three women and that if he hadn't been caught, he would still be killing. The three judges of the Supreme Court found Skrinik guilty of all charges and sentenced him to death. In 1981, Alexander Skrinik attended his date with the firing squad. On a chilly night in 1991, a group of teenagers gathered in their usual hangout, a barren
离开房间。随后，斯克里尼克毫无悔意地陈述了他的罪行。他告诉法庭，他享受谋杀这三名女性的过程，如果不是被抓，他还会继续杀人。最高法院的三名法官认定斯克里尼克所有罪名成立，并判处他死刑。1981年，亚历山大·斯克里尼克迎来了他的行刑队。1991年一个寒冷的夜晚，一群青少年聚集在他们通常的聚会地点——加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德附近一条繁忙高速公路旁的一片荒凉
stretch of desert next to a busy highway near Bakersfield, California. A dismal spot littered with trash and shell casings. By nightfall, it turned into a sort of lovers lane where high school kids drank and smoked. Then two boys left their group and headed into the darkness. They came upon a horrific scene. The body of a young woman murdered just hours before. She had no enemies besides girls at school, teenage stuff, not any kind of trouble that somebody would murder her.
沙漠地带。这是一个垃圾和弹壳遍地的阴沉地方。到了晚上，这里变成了一种“情人巷”，高中生们在这里喝酒抽烟。随后，两名男孩离开了他们的小团体，走向黑暗中。他们偶然发现了一个可怕的场景。一名年轻女性的尸体，就在几小时前被谋杀。她除了学校里的女生外没有敌人，都是些青少年之间的小事，根本不是那种会导致别人谋杀她的麻烦。
This 1991 murder made news headlines for years as it shocked and divided a quiet working-class community. Of course, I knew about Maria's case. Everyone in Bakersfield knows about Maria's case. They were glued to their TV sets and read the paper every day. There was a lot of speculation in Wasco that maybe he was not the all-around athlete that people thought he might be. When he lied about being her boyfriend, I felt like he had something to do with it.
这起1991年的谋杀案多年来一直占据新闻头条，因为它震惊并分裂了一个安静的工人阶级社区。当然，我知道玛丽亚的案子。贝克斯菲尔德的每个人都知道玛丽亚的案子。他们每天都盯着电视机看，读报纸。在瓦斯科（Wasco）有很多猜测，认为他可能并不是人们认为的那种全能运动员。当他撒谎说自己是她男友时，我觉得他肯定与此有关。
Justice took its course in a twisted and controversial case that captivated many. But what if the real killer were yet to be discovered? Because he warned me that he told me that I would tell the detectives that he was here when he wasn't really here. If you asked the sheriff's department and if you asked the prosecutor's office, they would say, yeah, we solved it. It's just unfortunate how things ended up. In this series, we will hear brand new clues, interview people that have never spoken publicly
正义在这一起扭曲且充满争议的案件中得到了伸张。但如果真正的凶手尚未被发现呢？因为他警告过我，他告诉我，我会告诉侦探他当时在这里，而他实际上并不在这里。如果你去问治安官办公室，如果你去问检察官办公室，他们会说，是的，我们破案了。事情最终以这种方式结束真是令人遗憾。在这个系列中，我们将听到全新的线索，采访从未公开谈论过的人，
before, and discover family secrets that shed light on who may have killed Maria Rodriguez and why. I kind of want all of our families hidden secrets in all of the dark past. I want it to come out to light. I'm Octavia McHenry for Case File Presents, and this is In the Shadows, the story of Maria Rodriguez. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并发现揭示谁可能杀害了玛丽亚·罗德里格斯（Maria Rodriguez）以及原因的家庭秘密。我有点想让我们所有家庭隐藏的秘密和所有黑暗的过去都曝光。我希望它能大白于天下。我是Case File Presents的奥克塔维亚·麦克亨利（Octavia McHenry），这就是《In the Shadows》，玛丽亚·罗德里格斯的故事。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。